bonsoir Alice le point sur lescho comme
chaque jeudi dans le 78 c'est avec vous
dans un instant un focus sur le premier
réseau d'un de financement et
d'accompagnement des entrepreneurs en
île-de-fance avec notre invité qui est
en plateau Philippe Margery bonsoir
bonsoir On va se tourner vers vous dans
un instant pour le moment un point sur
la situation à PSA oui mercredi dernier
une centaines de salariés en colère ont
investi les locaux du Pôle tercière de
poissie on le voit sur ces images PS
évalue les dégâts causés par les
manifestants à plus de 100000 € ils
étaient en tout entre 300 et 400
employés de poissie et d'oln sousbois à
être venus manifester à l'appel de la
CGT le groupe PSA a annoncé la
suppression de 8000 postes en fin
d'année la CGT dénonce 1500 sur pression
de postes supplémentaires des chiffres
que PSA considère comme des disparitions
de postes dues à des départs naturels
qui s'effectueront d'ici 2014 on vous
tiendra bien sûr informé de l'avancée
hein de ces manifestations au siège de
PS1 clim entendu en effet du côté de PSA
et pas uniquement dans le département
des ivelines on passe maintenant donc à
notre invité de cette chronique écho oui
alors bonoir Philippe Marguery vous êtes
donc prés président d'initiative 51 en
yeline c'est une association qui vient
en aide aux entreprises notamment en
accordant des prêts à taux zéro alors
expliquez-nous les prêts que vous
proposez la base c'est effectivement de
d'aider les entrepreneurs qu'il soi
créateurs ou des entreprises qui
préexistent déjà à pouvoir mieux se
financer mieux financer leur entreprise
donc on prête de l'argent au aux
entrepreneurs effectivement à taux zéro
les entrepreneurs après ça mettre
l'argent qu'on leur prête à la
disposition de leur entreprise alors il
y a une condition importante c'est que
on aide les entrepreneurs mais on se
substitue pas aux banques donc notre
prêt est conditionné par un un prêt
bancaire en parallèle hein donc on ne
prête que s'il y a en parallèle un prêt
bancaire est-ce que ça facilite
l'obtention d'un prêt bancaire non parce
qu' oui c'est mieux d'avoir votre ça
permet si vous voulez à l'entrepreneur
d'affirmer ou d'afficher qu'il a plus
d'apport personnel parce que comment on
lui prête à lui personnellement après
l'entrepreneur choix lui oui il a le
choix soit de le mettre dans son capital
c'est l'argent qui l'amène c'est lui qui
l'amène soit en compte courant enfin ça
fait partie de des apports qu' a le chef
d'entreprise oui quels sont les montants
de ces prêts alors ça dépend des types
de prêts que nous faisons par exemple le
prêt à la création d'entreprise le prêt
à la création d'entreprise est de 25000
€ maximum HM et reprise d'entreprise al
la reprise d'entreprise il est aussi de
de 25000 en ce qui concerne notre
financement à nous mais on peut obtenir
mécaniquement automatiquement à partir
du moment où nous nous l'avons accordé
un prêt de notre organisme au niveau
régional et pourquoi parce que du même
montant c'est plus difficile de
reprendre une
entreprisement est- ça nécessite
effectivement plus de fonds tout le
monde le comprend je pense une
entreprise qui préexiste déjà et
nécessite bah d'indemniser enfin de P
payer le prix d'achat de l'entreprise au
vendeurs donc les sommes généralement
mobilisées sont un peu plus élevées oui
c'est c'est difficile d'attribuer des
prêts quels sont les critères est-ce que
c'est compliqué alors c'est c'est
compliqué oui et c'est pour ça qu'on se
met à plusieurs il y a un comité
d'agrément comme dans une banque ce
comité d'agrément comprend bah des
banquiers justement des chefs
d'entreprise des experts comptables des
avocats des membres de la Chambre de
commerce de la Chambre des Métiers c'est
sous forme de jury en fait le chef
d'entreprise vient vous voir oui alors
avec oui tout à fait alors c'est un peu
particulier donc par rapport à ce que
d'habitude les les créateurs
d'entreprise ou les entrepreneurs deun
façon générale connaissent avec le
milieu bancaire c'est que nous ils
viennent exposer devant le comité leur
projet euh il l'exposent nous leur
posons des questions ils nous répondent
après ça ils s'écartent nous délibérons
entre nous et dans la même matinée dans
tout cela se suit et et nous leur
donnons la réponse c'est vraiment assez
particulier donc il y a concertation
entre l'entrepreneur et nous et puis il
y a des décisions immédiates et puis la
grande nouveauté pour votre association
c'est le fait que vous vous associez à
scientiple qui est une plateforme
régionale spécialisée dans les
prétechnologique innovant ce partenariat
c'est du donnant donnant c'est-à-dire
d'une part vous les aidez puis d'autre
part vous recevez une information
spécialisée une expertise alors
scientiple est effectivement une
plateforme comme nous mais au niveau
régional dont la spécificité est d'aider
les projets technologiques et donc nous
avons pensé à
50 an evling qu'il était intéressant
pour nous de d'avoir un accord
spécifique avec eux qui a été signé il y
a tout récemment il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises spécialisé dans dans
l'innovation dans les sciences à
Saint-Quentin bah c'est un peu si vous
voulez
Saint-Quentin je pense que tous nos
auditeurs connaissent cette cette ville
cette agglomération il il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises elle a une image quand
même assez technologique alors on
finance des projets résidentiels
d'économie résidentiel hein tel que je
sais pas des restaurants par exemple
mais on est amené aussi à à financer des
projets plus technologiques plus
innovant et on souhaite aller dans cette
direction là plus que aujourd'hui avec
une capacité euh meilleure d'expertise
donc scientipol peut vous y aider alors
scientipol comme ils sont spécialisés
dans ces projets innovants
technologiques euh ils ont à leur
disposition un certain nombre d'experts
et donc nous voulons profiter de ces
experts d'une part et d'autre part ça
nous permet aussi de cofinancer les les
projets les projets technologiqu sont
souvent des projets qui l' aussi comme
pour la reprise mobilise plus de fonds
et donc nous mettons si j'ose dire AUAU
et et sentip est capable de faire la
même chose on va continuer à parler
d'initiative Saint-Quentin dans un
instant vous restez en plateau avec nous
Philippe Marguery on va juste faire une
petite pause on va partir pour la
verrière on va découvrir ce reportage on
va parler logement à présent avec une
première dans cette commune oui cela
faisait 40 ans que la ville n'avait pas
eu de projet immobilier pour cette
petite ville de 6200 habitants c'est un
événement regardez ce
reportage c'est historique de nouvelles
habitations verront bientôt le jour dans
le quartier du Bois de l'étan à La
Verrière 82 exactement cela faisait 40
ans que la ville n'avait pas eu de
nouvelles constructions quand vous venez
à La Verrière vous avez deux façons
d'habiter soit vous habitez dans du
logement collectif social soit vous
habitez dans un petit pavillon que vous
achetez sur un terrain de 400 m mais il
y a rien d'autre et donc il fallait
effectivement d'autres formes d'habitat
qui permettent à des jeunes couples de
d'accéder dans du petit collectif par
exemple ces habitations sont accessibles
en location accession mode privilégié
par les primos accédant ce processus
d'acquisition qui date de 1984 n'avait
pas bonne presse mais récemment de réels
avantages lui ont été conférés on
bénéficie maintenant pour ce type
d'acquisition d'une TVA t réduit
maintenant à 7 % al est passé de 5,5 à 7
%. d'une exénération d'impô fonciers
pendant 15 ans et de pas de cumul de
charge pendant la construction pour un
trois pièces compter 180000 € et 240000
€ pour une maison de quatre pièces les
travaux devraient commencer en janvier
prochain déjà 10 acquéreurs se sont
positionnés l'espace vente est situé en
face de la gare SNCF livraison de la
résidence prévue début
2015 et nous sommes toujours avec
Philippe Marguery président d'initiative
Saint-Quentin une association qui
finance donc les entreprises en le en
leur acccordant pardon des prêts à taux
zéro vous êtes rattaché à la Maison de
l'Entreprise de Saint-Quentin vous
comptez une trentaine de membres quatre
salariés à temps partiel vous avez aidé
une quarantaine d'entreprise c'est bien
ça en 2012 est-ce que c'est plus ou
moins que les années précédentes ce
n'est pas une bonne année je dois le
dire parce que bah parce que le le
climat économique est pas tout à fait là
quoi ce qui est vrai pour Saint-Quentin
est vrai pour l'ensemble de la région il
de France et j'ai peur pour l'ensemble
de la France c'est les échos que nous
avons au sein du réseau France enfin
initiative France oui parce que tout à
fait he vous êtes rattaché à une
plateforme nationale initiative France
présidée par Louis schetzer l'ancien PDG
de Renault comment êtes-vous financer
alors notre financement est multiple ce
sont à la fois des financements privés
d'entreprises euh par exemple nous avons
eu des fonds de Talis dans des fonds de
H des grands groupes de DF d'un certain
nombre de grands groupes oui et puis
nous avons aussi des fonds qui
proviennent de la région Île-de-France
des fonds de la Caisse des dépôts et
consignations et puis il y a une
contribution forte de la communauté
d'agglomération de 5 en yvelin qui nous
finance à la fois une participation fond
de prê mais aussi qui met à notre
disposition comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure du personnel et puis des locaux
alors comment les entreprises les chefs
d'entreprisees qui nous regardent
peuvent prendre contact avec vous est-ce
qu'il faut obblatoement passer par une
banque absolument pas soit vous adressez
directement alors le mieux la porte
d'entrée c'est la Maison de l'Entreprise
oui on va voir les coordonnées
s'affichées à l'écran et alors soit vous
vous allez voir votre enfin le
l'entrepreneur va voir son banquier et
son banquier qui nous connaît en
principe répercute sur nous ou alors les
entrepreneurs s'adressent directement à
la maison d'entreprise à notre
association et nous d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs on peut les orienter vers des
banquers que que nous connaissons merci
beaucoup Philippe Marguerie d'être venu
en plateau